Florence berjoub black l'air vous êtes
venus pour une conférence sur le thème
savoir et censure évidemment ça fait
suite à la publication de votre livre le
vrai risque BC réseau chez Odile Jacob
c'est ce livre vous savez un peu
commencé à vous mais qui vous a attiré
des menaces de mort des choses qui qui
nous renvoie une période qu'on croirait
révolue de l'Université du savoir
justement et de la censure oui si
j'étais un petit peu le cobaye de cette
séance puisque je ne faisais pas
l'analyse de livres du contenu du livre
mais plutôt j'ai essayé de donner
quelques éléments d'éclairage sur mon
expérience de chercheur effectivement
surprise par la violence des des
intimidations des menaces des pressions
qui continuent d'avoir lieu autour de
moi et de mon ouvrage et surtout
l'absence et c'est ça qui est
remarquable de critique de fond
véritable critique de fond qui ne sont
pas encore arrivés alors il y a quelques
petites recensions qui sont bientôt
favorable à mon livre mais pour ce qui
est de mes contempteurs ils n'ont
toujours pas sorti de véritables
arguments fondés sur la
conceptualisation que je propose et
c'est ça qui est un petit peu
particulier c'est à la fois cette
violence et cette vacuité de la part de
certains collègues qu'est-ce que cette
violence blocage nous nous dit de
l'université française de l'Université
au principe c'est le lieu en effet des
savoirs et on ne peut tout à fait ne pas
être d'accord avec une thèse mais mais
mais il y a une discussion et une
disputes qu'on vous disiez des
discussions qu'est-ce que ça dit
aujourd'hui c'est blocage de diversité
française l'université est mal emploi
pour ne pas dire malade alors
heureusement il y a comme aujourd'hui
des résistants des gens qui
s'interrogent sur ces problèmes de
liberté académique le problème aussi
c'est que c'est au nom de la liberté
académique qu'on veut faire taire des
gens comme moi c'est ça qui est
paradoxal c'est que les ennemis de la
liberté d'expression utilise leur
liberté de faire cancer d'une certaine
manière c'est ça qui est très
particulier et je crois que ce qui est
plus inquiétant c'est l'autocensure
c'est à dire le fait d'anticiper un
événement violent même s'il n'y a aucun
signe que ça va se produire comme ça ça
a été le cas pour moi lors de la
conférence annulée ou plutôt reportée de
la Sorbonne il n'y avait pas de signe
d'inquiétude et pourtant la Sorbonne a
décidé de suspendre mon ma conférence ce
qui a provoqué le
la réassurance chez certains c'était
critique de mon livre sans l'avoir lu
c'était la preuve qu'il y avait quelque
chose
or vous êtes pardon vous êtes vous
appartenez au CNRS vous êtes une
chercheuse alors que reconnu même si
vous êtes contesté par un certain nombre
scientifique il faut être contester mais
sur la base d'arguments véritable et qui
prouve que la personne l'a lu pas de
Thierry picking où on prend un certain
mot sur certaines pages on dit ah bah
voyez elle a dit ça complètement hors
contexte non non il faut avoir compris
ce qu'a voulu faire l'auteur et ensuite
en appartient c'est comme ça qu'on
travaille en sciences et tout à l'heure
vous avez dit voilà depuis depuis la
publication de ce livre alors votre
travail universitaire est comme devenu
extrêmement difficile vous pouvez pas
avoir des étudiants parce que ça ne
gâcherait peut-être leur carrière parce
que le le secteur est tenu par une
certaine idéologie
est-ce que vous êtes pas aussi victime
de ce mouvement comme ça vous dit pas de
Vannes quoi oui il y a le pas de
valdisme comme on dit il y a l'acheter
mais il y a surtout ce qu'on pouvait
appeler la l'irresponsabilité plus
personne ne se sent responsable la
grande machine à produire de la
connaissance fonctionne chacun à son
petit salaire à la fin du mois
les médias s'emparent de certains sujets
en font des choses complètement
différentes de ce qui a été produit
vraiment dans la reine universitaire et
puis ça continue comme ça c'est pour ça
que cette conférence l'a montré il nous
faut réfléchir maintenant sur les moyens
de véritablement protéger la liberté de
recherche et de réfléchir ensemble avec
les étudiants moi j'étais surpris et
beaucoup d'étudiants aujourd'hui donc il
s'intéresse véritablement au sujet et
ils ont raison il faut réfléchir avec
eux au moyen de d'améliorer cette
situation là il y a une chose c'est que
voilà vous faites des conférences sur sa
voix et sensuelle du coup
le on parle presque plus du fond du fond
du livre ce qui est ce qui est quand
même dommage
il vient de sortir
je sais que en tout cas moi je suis
contacté par les Britanniques les Danois
les Suédois les Indiens aussi
s'intéressent à mon livre donc je me
fais pas de souci il va revenir et cette
fois-ci on part on parlera du fond merci
beaucoup merci à vous